une journée difficile pour la famille de
nikita goldblum koné qui l'épuisé la
petite nicole trois ans et demi est
arrivée avec son père et sa mère
nathalie dans ce campement de fortune
d'ukrainiens qui arrivent par milliers
depuis des semaines ici
la
partie de la pologne leur voyage aura
duré 24 heures pour arriver à tijuana
sur la côte ouest du mexique plus rien
ne retenait la famille dans son pays
tout ce qui lui reste se trouve dans ces
quelques bagages
il a fait comme tous ces ukrainiens qui
n'ont pas voulu attendre des mois pour
avoir des nouvelles de leur dossier
d'immigration déposés dans des
ambassades américaines en europe et
qu'ils étaient submergés par les
demandes de réfugiés ou de demandeurs
d'asile alors ils ont profité d'une
exemption spéciale de l'administration
maiden qui leur permettait de traverser
la frontière terrestre via le mexique
alors que celle ci est fermée à
l'ensemble des migrants depuis le début
de la pandémie en 2020
depuis le début de l'invasion russe
anastassia bolo cofondatrice de united
for you run dit avoir accueilli près de
12000 personnes ici des personnes de
passage à quelques minutes de la
frontière dans ce centre sportif
transformé en dortoir mais tous ces
ukrainiens exténué par leur périple et
les déchirements d'avoir dû quitter leur
pays et leur famille sont probablement
parmi les derniers à pouvoir profiter de
l'accueil des autorités américaines car
depuis minuit ce pas ce droit n'existe
plus pour ceux qui ont fui la guerre en
scène les caisses le gaz aux massages et
ce principe en est à sa mère et du beau
basket
enrique lucera hauts responsables des
services aux migrants à la ville de
tijuana sait que cela sera difficile
pour certains de ces ukrainiens
non mais dans l'aude down house kings 3
n'a été
donnée ni
[Musique]
mauvaise
dans ce camp nous rencontrons aussi
pavel sa femme aliona et leur fils de 12
ans dima leur cas est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ceux des ukrainiens ici il
est russe et a quitté moscou après avoir
manifesté contre la guerre dans un
rachat
[Musique]
il ne sait pas ce qui va lui arriver car
les services d'immigration américaine ne
veulent pas l'aider
locservice il ne peut même plus
retourner dans son pays son fils veut
quand même croire à un meilleur avenir
de l'autre côté de la frontière
[Musique]
pendant ce temps à la station bolo songe
déjà à d'autres idées pour éviter que
tous ces ukrainiens soient laissés à eux
mêmes à tijuana
à nu à
puce dans quelques minutes nikita
passera la frontière pour aller vivre à
san diego chez des amis
un avenir qui ne le fera donc pas
retourner en ukraine il construira plus
tôt sa nouvelle vie aux etats unis mais
il pensera à ses semblables qui ne
traverseront pas de sitôt cette
frontière pourtant tant espérée ici
frédéric arnould radio-canada à tijuana
au mexique